nous sommes une crise civique majeure et
je crois et que notre rôle est de
construire une alternative crédible pour
éviter que dans cinq ans on est une
alternative simplement entre l'extrême
gauche et le rassemblement national donc
nous devons à la fois être très
pragmatique sur les textes et défendent
de conviction à chaque examen texte
faire valoir nos valeurs nos principes
pour l'ordre pour la liberté de création
pour l'unité de la nation et puis
parallèlement ne ne pas être assimilé à
un conglomérat au pouvoir aujourd'hui
qui n'a pas de directives c'est aussi ça
et de lignes directrices ont pardonné
mois on dit que le pouvoir manque de
majorité je crois qu il manque surtout
d'un projet c'est surtout ça le problème